bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
vidéo aujourd'hui on est chez google et
youtube space paris on avait crise
fabien et victor qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de tourner entouré de fond
vert je suis dans le jeu c'est vrai quoi
la vie je suis dans un jeu vidéo c'est
génial on va jouer à plusieurs jeux
envers des jeux tir des jeux de baston
des jeux un peu fou comme celui ci on
n'était pas à l'agenda jorg butt à
l'heure c'est faire semblant de
descendre de ce record est alors
qu'andré ces fours ses plats je suis au
même niveau on est dans un mini-jeu de
là mais il ya des gens qui vont attaquer
ce château il faut que j'attaque ces
gens qui vont attaquer le château c'est
très simple j'ai mon arc
ici en chair et en os donc je baise lui
merci on applaudit merci à tous voilà
c'est parti donc lui c'est un barbare il
est né p tain mais je suis tellement
naze mais ce n'est pas pratique à
l'époque comme disait qu un [ __ ] mais
qu'ils arrivent ils sont énormément
d'endroits les alliages au lieu de chott
pièce testud affaire le king surveille
son village gens paniquent gens
paniquent je suis le pire guerrier ok
j'ai retiré son casque
non non non c'est vrai ça mais c'est
pour ça [ __ ] les gars même pas
missions du jeu
bah ouais quand tu veux j'anticipe après
je suis hyper des allées l'homme avec
son drapeau est décédé hier je veux tu
dis si un mec non mais franchement
appelez moi à rouen appelez moi la série
pour adolescents de 13 ans en le mec
mais défendent temps mais j'en ai marre
des maîtres comme ça il me fait chier au
collage à l'épervier
il continue dans les jeux une telle
solution l'explosion
qu'est ce qui va faire petit attaquant
smap non alors on va faire par priorité
priorité aux mecs qui sont là ok non non
non tu veux pas cette peur prenant lui
devient tête la tête
merde au [ __ ] mais qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qu'on était cool c'est
qu'il ya un ventilo qui simule le vent
de la vallée personne ne m'écoute ces
barrages
[Musique]
après avoir joué avec un arc et des
flèches on va jouer avec the rock
voilà qui habite au cinéma maintenant il
est visible dans un bar excellent par
william blême mon bras vous le voyez
normal d'accord parce que moi avec mes
bras sont fusionnés sur gaza il fait aux
riches parce qu'il est en train de me
maire de vote mais les gars vous fait
jouer à un regain d'efforts mais là et
en face il ya des gabarits moyens trop
mal moi je suis là je les regarde dans
un sac huawei qu'est ce qu'on va faire
et le mec est immense je lui arrive au
tt c'est incroyable à temps mais que
j'ai trop peur d'un stage j'ai trouvé le
petit mec kaba lui voilà le mec qui
fasse bien sean toujours préparer le
terrain avant de lancer une baston règle
numéro 1 créée par un mec qui sait
jamais vous tuer des monstres eh bien
non attention leurs proches ça marche
pas très bons amis grande claque mais
[ __ ] qui fait peur mais pourquoi il
joue à la mêlée en faites quoi laisser
le trône mais je croyais faire point les
gars tu fais qu'est ce que tu fais
qu'est ce que tu fais qu'est ce que tu
fais et testud fait mon gars voilà reste
à terre reste à terre est ce qui veut
dire tu vas faire zita dans la bouteille
[Musique]
franchement les gens ne se bas je suis
parce qu'ils se barrent mais l'ambiance
est un peu chelou quoi hommes pardon au
pardon mais non plus la seule fille cool
du bar elle veut cela est contre moi à
tintin tintin mais tout cas ce n'est
plus ma deuxième neuf
la plupart d'eau excuse moi mais en fait
je suis mort ça un peu je suis mort
j'avais pas fait gaffe ça c'est moi en
fait ma vie actuellement un bon 2e tour
pour nick et des mers et je parle dans
la tienne bon mec je vais marcher
jusqu'aux dents à tort est ce que je
peux ouais alors là alors là mon pote
deux d'un coup mais remet à cannes
non car toi tu me fais un seul but tu me
fatigues toi tu es tu dans l'espace buzz
oh merde j'attends d'en brûler tout le
bar qu'est ce qui fait qu est-ce qui
c'est quoi cet endroit de tout allait
bien jusqu'à ce que tu fasses a nommé
d'éloges non exploité des laisses montre
le pardon non je veux juste aider
pardon mais [ __ ] c'est contagieux au
courage je vais t'aider mais je crois
que je peux juste taper je veux t d je
suis en train de télé je vais t'aider je
vais t'aider mais tu fais quoi toi le
mail qui s'incruste dans brouille
ça dégage direct j'ai entendu un petit
conseil je serai plus fort si je bois
il ya une bosse qui a dit ça ce que je
suis bien je parle régulièrement anglais
mec
peut dire que là on va enchaîner ça
c'est fait la sismique pas des mers
franchement désolé de le dire mais c'est
qu'il ya un gros problème c'est quoi
enfin inverse alors que y'a pas ton pote
pour teddy tu fais moi le mal à l'épaule
mon pote les boules froch roberts
academy à ça c'est la puissance de
franck la fnbs épilepsie voilà il part
tendance il fait un pli for my dance
mais dans ce cas le comte [ __ ] bon à
la je pense que je considère que je te
battu sans rancune mais mais quoi il ne
fait pas en vrai il fait sauf quand il
fait ça quand il fait ça j'ai plus
partagés mais attends je le reprends je
surprends dans les moules franck robert
tu sais quand je bois je suis fort m élu
par coup je crois que j'ai vraiment
cassé son cerveau il ya vraiment un gros
problème pour les petites bières si bien
on va se poser sur le tabouret ça ok les
gars faut qu'on se venge sur ces
mesdames
alors tu m'a mal parlé tout à l'heure
j'aimerais que tu baisse les yeux quand
je te parle je te plaît robert pardon
merde est superbe et à la daronne
mondiale va mieux que les hommes on a la
tête des esquives alors très droit à
tendance non non par contre elle avec
son équipe de merde ça dégage tu as je
me bats comme un enfant qua non non aux
lecteurs tout va bien se passer
voulait-on relève toi or je revive
macaques bonjour bonjour je suis l'homme
qui va casser des culs et nick et des
maires je vais utiliser un petit peu
avant et là on est paré on s'approche
doucement en pause de lyon est là les
amis franck robert tu sais quoi
ces deux testicules à gauche à droite et
on tape dedans
moi je fais des techniques de bâtard mon
gars voilà il arrive pas à m'atteindre
taz le balaye et lac ou dans les boules
et c'est normal qu'est ce que tu vas
faire tes affaires as montlouis par un
autre à plat ni vu ni connu
l'anaconda on l'appelle pas à les salir
ouais ouais mon pote on fait le train
et bien bonjour et bienvenue dans mon
échoppe dans mon combiné à je vous lâche
plus que le japon c'est terrible c'est
terrible combiné au japon sem exactions
ouvert 24/24 et jours sur 7 est-ce que
là pour parler du japon non aux
particuliers en suivant me connaissez je
sais le tout premier auquel on a joué en
vert annoncé le deuxième je sais plus je
suis au dessus bord de mer je ne sais
plus alors on accueille un client est ce
que je peux voler sa pipe hop ça c'est
une très belle journée
alors il veut quoi je n'ai je pas écouté
il veut peut-être sa pipe du coup juste
là pour celles dont on attend avec
sasson avril veut juste un truc genre
tout comme excuse juste ça c'est à dire
quoi ça mes mecs quand tu viens un super
match et une tendresse pas aux questions
lui disant frères donne moi ce que tu
veux c'est toi qui arrivent et qui lui
donne ce que tu veux acheter est ce qu
est ce que je lui file un bruit tautavel
tafna un burrito les avions pensé quoi
je trouve ça pas mal rires francs tout
le mec prend tout un bon bretzel mon
gars il le prend il prend tout à fait
elle cache sa marche lavit avec les
suivants combat à tes conneries ok
cowboy la date des mois tous quelqu'un
qu'on pense qui dit je crois qu'il
enfants tendent vers une crise
d'hypoglycémie mais qu'il a basé dessus
de la glace bleue bien chimique c'est
pour toi mon attente autant non mais non
je vais pas scanner un bon mec je les
passe kahn avant [ __ ] je me suis dit
oui et ben moi en place je te prends
tous les deux ans en échange
qu'est ce tu vas faire jeu des volets
tes lunettes mon pote alors qui je me
tape au [ __ ] c'est un braquage
vingt ans d'âge est un mec franck
roberts quoi je connais bien la baston
on a bien vu il ya je les fais quoi
comme l'a fait pour avoir ri gun ok ok
le coffre il est où il est là c'est bon
il est là il a lâché le coach et le café
comme c'est mon tire pas dessus tiens
tiens je te donne tout mais lingots de
fromage à les matins au plafond couverte
hockey suivant il s'est vraiment le
meilleur jeu en verre franchement est-ce
qu'au fond de nous on n'a pas tous
toujours eu envie d'être caissier
finalement bon alors qu'ils ont suivant
hall et villareal veulent acheter de
l'alcool ils font semblant peut voir une
carte d'identité
est ce que ce n'est pas une fausse carte
d'identité apparemment le scanner crois
que c'est un vrai duel quoi ils veulent
des pétards [ __ ] ils veulent des
bisons 4 attend comme un jour d'accord
c'est carrément mis sous clé et tout un
[ __ ] les mecs c'est du bison 8 merde
merde
tiens tiens tiens c'est pour toi c'est
pour toi tu prends le feu d'artifice
prend le bon bref ils veulent ça et ils
veulent ça mais non mais much mais c'est
pas possible ça va faire quoi saper
attend ça a pété salle c'est super long
ah mais c'est juste une
d'accord c'est une note c'est ce
qu'assurent les gâteaux quoi allez
prenez les gars ouais et poster bande
d'enculés tient maintenant
[ __ ] chaque fois je me fais avoir son
âme à ces pays
mais ce jeu était trop bien on s'est
jamais autant amusé chez white space lui
égalité environ n'hésite pas viens viens
dans mon échoppe base il n'ya pas de
souci tu peux venir
attention alors on a 8 ans c'est génial
qu'est ce que tu veux l'alcool à la hâte
en frère tu vas pas être déçu tiens à
faire c'est l'alcool parce que je pense
que j'ai pas de moneta pas de monnaie
police police
[Musique]
bon c'est bien d'être caissier mais là
on a step up là on est garagiste mon
pote on va mettre les mains dans l'huile
on va réparer des moteurs tout ce qui
est viril bonjour monsieur m'écraser pas
pour bien commencer déjà la vidéo
or quel beau moteur [ __ ] mais quel
beau moteur il faut juste quoi il faut
mettre des fluides à temps mais c'est
quoi ta facon gars faut que je verse sa
sur ça mais ça n'a pas de sens un
intranet de l'huile sur un flan préparez
vos voitures comme ça bon c'est quoi ce
bordel
ok je te remets ton fin mai ou alors il
faut prendre du sucre qu'est-ce que du
sucre vient faire dans une histoire de
réparation de voitures à six futurs
d'accord c'est les neiges du hcc en fait
ok ok oui c'est ça ça marche au sucre et
oui cela c'est à dire que c'est fini
oh [ __ ] il m'a fait suer avec sa
voiture [ __ ] mais il n'y a pas fini
quoi qu'il faut que je fasse une facture
avec facture ok pour son compteur à 3524
de la grosse facture dont grosse facture
je comprends que j'en ai besoin ça c'est
fait oh [ __ ] je me sens et fusé après
cette journée je vais manger une petite
banane sont frédéric ça fait du bien à
les voitures suivantes patinoire j'en ai
marre de ces jeux où tu travailles pour
de faux on l'a eu une petite voiture ce
que je peux vous les langues ou un frère
frère sur le titien retrait scottish à
ok il ya un problème de phares problème
de phare le phare cassé affectivement il
a cassé ses fins il a dû mentir dans un
make up up on va lui changer sans
problème je commence à m'habituer je
commence à être un bon mécano hop hop on
lui remet attention à ce que vous êtes
prêts au fait de 1up et deux de ses neuf
onces applaudit bien fort s'il vous
plaît qu'est-ce qu'on a encore un moteur
roquettois pistons influent liquide un
très bon produit il faut changer le
filtre r bien sûr bien évidemment du
coup ça doit être dans la haine recuite
europe on est bon et voilà alors il veut
changer la couleur on va faire
du vert voilà bourne est bon ça dégage
un aller brita la facture pardon pour le
comptable excuse moi pardon c'est
important à allez hop c'est pour toi ça
dégage le mec a quand même payer 3800 $
pour que je change un filtre on en parle
ou pas de l'escroquerie
ok suivant un taxi est frère désolé je
vais pas reculer hubert ouais c'est la
fin de cette vidéo
mais recevoir il ya des vidéos n'hésitez
pas allez mais ça vous a plu merci où
es-tu space voir permis de réaliser ça
c'était hyper marrant de s'incruster
dans un jeu en temps réel j'ai fait ça
au sahara que c'est du matériel de
ballades sambre est finie c'était chiant
à mettre en place
merci à vous les gars je vous applaudis
que vous m'avez applaudi quelques je
suis soldat d'autres moins bien et puis
après une prochaine vidéo je cherchais
vous a plu au revoir franck roberts
[Musique]
ça